We thank the President of Cuba for his
speech and I am pleased that
Azerbaijan’s cooperation with the
Eurasian Economic Community countries, with the exception of Armenia, has been
successfully developing for 30 years.
There are serious prerequisites for
the normalization of relations between
Azerbaijan and Armenia on the basis of
mutual recognition of territorial
integrity and sovereignty. Today, at the
initiative of the Russian side, a
trilateral meeting will be held.  Heads of Russia
Armenia and Azerbaijan Thank you very much to our
colleagues for our joint
work today, because of your participation in this
work, I give the floor to the chairman of the
commission,
the defeat that has been used
as a title
for the movement of territorial claims
against Armenia in recent years.
statements November 9, 2020 I want to
emphasize that this statement
refers to only one corridor and this is the
Latin corridor, which was supposed to
be under the control of Russian
peacekeepers but unfortunately
illegally blocked by
Azerbaijan, please allow me to simply
answer and say that Azerbaijan has
not blocked any corridor that
As for the Lachin-Khanki road, it is
open on the border between Armenia and
Azerbaijan, which you
recognize, a border checkpoint has been established.
In accordance with all
international standards, this
border checkpoint is located
20 meters from the post of the
Russian peacekeeping contingent
and today residents pass through this
border checkpoint
Azerbaijanis of Armenian nationality
who live in Karabakh
move freely towards Armenia, there are
no obstacles, we will have the opportunity
now. As we agreed in the
trilateral format, we can talk about everything calmly
in a businesslike manner and I
hope to reach some agreements
that will lead to such a
constructive development of the situation
only between the army and Azerbaijan, but also
in the region as a whole,
this is a member state of the Eurasian Economic Community as